[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing fred weasley
george weasley and the marauders map
george and fred weasley were the closest
of brothers
identical in every way and by far the
most mischievous members of the weasley
family
they were the kind of twins that would
spend every waking moment with one
another
and tackle any obstacle together the
obstacle that i'm going to be discussing
today
however pertains to the famous marauders
map a magical map used by the marauders
sirius black james potter remus lupin
and peter pettigrew
during their time at hogwarts the
marauders map
is described as follows the magic used
in the map's creation
is advanced and impressive it includes
the homunculus charm
enabling the possessor of the map to
track the movements of every person in
the castle
and it was also enchanted to forever
repel as insultingly as possible
the curiosity of the nemesis severus
snape george and fred came into
possession of the map
after stealing it from filtra's office
during their first year at hogwarts
the pair had gotten in trouble for
setting off a dung bomb a notice to draw
marked confiscated and highly dangerous
which obviously caught their attention
their curiosity got the better of them
and while george dropped another dung
bomb
fred was able to search the draw and
steal the map this was a great find
especially for a mischievous pair like
fred and george the map allowed them to
see every inch of every classroom
hallway nook and cranny of the castle
which allowed them to get up to all
sorts of mischief
undetected not only that but the map
showed people
in real time this allowed them to easily
escape the likes of snape and filch
with all of that being said the
marauders map gave the holder or in this
case holders
a lot of power this little beauty has
taught us more than all the teachers in
this school
however one thing that i've always
wondered is how fred and george were
able to use the map
if you didn't know already the map
itself is actually password protected
this was a preventative measure to
ensure that not just anyone could take
advantage of its capabilities
to delay person the map wouldn't appear
as magical at all
in fact it would just look like a blank
piece of parchment when harry is first
given the map by fred and george
he has no idea what to think of it this
harry is the secret of our success
it's a wrench giving it to you but we
decided last night your needs greater
than ours
anyway we know it by heart we bequeath
it to you we don't really need it
anymore
and what do i need with a bit of old
parchment but the question remains
how on earth did fred and george figure
out the password to the map in the first
place
there's no way they would have gotten it
from one of the original marauders so
how'd they do it i solemnly swear that i
am up to no good
had they worked that one out it turns
out that jk rowling was actually asked
this exact question in an interview with
mugglenet
how did they figure out how to work the
map don't you
well this is how i explained it to
myself at the time and this does sound
glib
don't you think it would be quite a fred
and george's thing to say in jest and
then
see this thing transform yeah can't you
just see them
but the exact word combination is that
just a lot of luck or
felix felicis or the map helped
yep yeah you can see them sort of
answering and joking with each other
and the map flickering into life here
and there when they got closer and
closer
and finally they hit upon the exact
right word combination and it just
erupts
what jk rowling explains here is that
fred and george figured out the password
with a little luck
some playful effort and perhaps a little
help from the map itself through
prodding and probing
they were able to analyze feedback from
the map eventually
figuring out the exact word combinations
necessary to reveal its secrets
trial and error their playful nature and
a little bit of luck worked out for them
in the end and that's it for this video
did you guys ever wonder how those two
actually figured it out
did you suspect a different answer let
me know in the comment section
below until next time i solemnly swear
that i am up to no good
[Music]